[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist der dreizehnte mai 2006
ein freudenfest für die fcz-fans für
roland maag endete sie
der faustschlag hat schwere folgen für
roland
und verändert die schweizerische
rechtsprechung der sudan hat sicheres
signal wirklich und man muss sich also
besser bewusst sie wenn er driesch laut
vermutlich abschlag dass das eine der
parzellen ist
[Musik]
doch der meister und deinen
zürich april 2013 mit seinem freund
nathan kehrt roland marx in die
markthalle zurück an den ort wo der
verhängnisvolle abend vor sieben jahren
seinen anfang nahm
samstag abend im st jakob park in basel
im final der schweizer fußball
meisterschaft deutet alles auf einen
sieg der basler hängen
die stimmung ist explosiv
unmittelbar vor dem abpfiff schießt
philipp s oder siegestor für die zürcher
[Applaus]
gewalt überschattet die fußballfreude
[Musik]
die ausschreitungen gehen unter dem
titel die schande von basel in die
fußball geschichte ein
[Applaus]
roland marx und sein jugendfreund nathan
verfolgten das spiel in der markthalle
sind markthalle nach dir benannt
da links ist das screening sie auf der
bühne alles vorliegt
[Applaus]
2 cm wir alles ohne flogen nach der
rückkehr aus basel lassen sich die fcz
helden von ihren fans in der zürcher
maag halle feiern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
roland marx kann sich an die feier noch
bruchstückhaft erinnern der im moment
wird man ihre gäste sehen wir dich um
vergess ich eigentlich was ich würde
stimmig sieht also diese mega stimmig
sie auch im glück wird sie und natürlich
freut und sind dann die thermalquelle
medaillengarant irgendwie schwierig ich
habe hier so viel wie lüd um
abenteuerlich werden dann und gesichtern
und je so viel man einmalig und
[Musik]
extremisten
das ist die hälfte zeit meistertitel
dementsprechend engagiert sich der
roland für einig sie vom vorschlag jede
rolle schwimmerin jamaika lebensfroher
enthusiastische typ sie offerierte st
natürlich für jeden möglich jeder sei
und viel zusammen erlebt und
wahrscheinlich sie war nicht immer so ne
sicher vom labor getarnt dass jeder
situation eine dass ein wechsel aber
nicht extra probiert hast schwierig zu
machen oder oder einmal straße begleitet
damit man auf der sonne sicher lauf
zum zeitpunkt des schicksalsschlages ist
roland marx 28 jahre alt ein
lebensfroher geselliger und
unbeschwerter junger mann
die kleineren schweizer siegenthaler
die sind die zange gewachsen schrieb mir
sage rolli ist ein leidenschaftlicher
fußballspieler
aufgewachsen ist er in rüschlikon am
zürichsee die berufstätige mutter zieht
ihren einzigen sohn alleine groß vor dem
karosserie spengler liegt eine
vielversprechende zukunft in die zukunft
ich ganz klar die familie zahlt sowie
sagen die rede
jeder junge mensch oder fehlende viele
junge menschen sich ziel sind also ganz
normal die laufbahn wunsch trank sie vor
ihm oder mit der familie mccann und das
ist schon den wunsch wieder und wieder
als ableger so und das ist im prinzip
schon nach stunden oder ist so zu nach
der freinacht verlassen rolle und seine
freunde das party areal vor dem von der
party location bis dafür dazu der
estavis bruck und vor ostern langsam aus
dem handel sei nicht als würden wir sind
natürlich hungrig sie sich schon morgen
früher sie
der größte teil vor seiner gruppe ist
abgestellt
roli bleibt mit einem kollegen unter der
hardbrücke zurück sein verhängnis
und dann ist kollegin atomkrieg und
rolli schäffer schlager wurde
da bin ich schockiert darüber galt und
dann habe ich ihn am bodensee und das
hat mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass
er aus der blüte das natürlich sehr
besorgniserregend ist und wahrscheinlich
nichts los sei
ronnie schlauri ist an roland marx seite
als diese den verhängnisvollen
faustschlag kassiert rowling sind davor
nicht 100 proben ein kollege nicht davon
formieren
dass der typ-2 heck oder belästigt oder
was auch immer
und damit frei wählen und dann hat sie
dafür gezeigt oder und dann plötzlich
und sie wird straße in münchen sieht
oder und in dem moment angeordnet
verdacht dass ihr ziel gemäß passiert
und dann ist der oli zu gesprungen
[Musik]
und dann stieg sie also das ist wie wenn
in velen pause tastendruck stein ist
ruhig sie kastrieren und umgekommen
du bist nur fokussiert und gesessen und
hass vieler manager stellt jetzt wo die
ruhr das für ein fuß als polizei und
sanität am tatort eintreffen machen sich
ronny und seine kollegen auf die suche
nach den tätern
also mir dann vor ort an dem luther vor
dass das die richtige führer koffer sind
escher wyss platz und dann im siegbogen
sind oder wir sind dann noch lange ich
unterbreite vom norden hat sie dann noch
doch wollen wir dann wirklich billig sie
sind und wie beruf schlosser arbeitet
und sie eigentlich keine sind sie ihn
als ruine flüge der brite vom norden hat
zum glück gerade noch in die erste
nummer der märker
[Musik]
heinz [ __ ] waren dabei der
kantonspolizei zürich hat die erste
einvernahme des täters gemacht
er schildert dessen perspektive
die beide gruppen sind auf dem platz
gestanden und späteren opfer ist aus
irgendeiner richtig co das weiß man
nicht so genau zu der gruppe h und dann
hat jeder verbale großen schritte mit
den alle in der version des täters an
roland marx einen bierbecher in der hand
gehalten haben denn rund einfach die
person und wirft noch am bache gegen
einen kollegen und das geschäft genug
sie waren das hatte das ist nicht das
thema es einige fahrer los und
austrinken die cherry oder ein über zur
anderen gruppe und hat womöglich mit
einer härte vorschlag zu schlagen
da auf seite sie gewinnen baumstamm auf
die wurde kate und erregen es gehört
wurde am boden aufschlagen ob es denn
besser gegeben hat ob ihr geworfen wurde
und jemanden getroffen hat bleibt
ungeklärt
in den akten steht der auslöser ist ein
wichtiger grund
nach dem vorschlag der kragen ich sehe
natürlich ganzen hoch wirksam wurden auf
den vorfall
junge mann bot alexej grischin hat da
stehen braucht vitalität riefen polizei
und es ungemütlich wurde für die
tätergruppe und präsentierte
folgerichtig kairos und das alte papier
ist von einer kollegin die tätergruppen
ist ob zur status hat sie realisiert was
dabei passiert ist auch den usa oder
nach einzelnen user haben rufen heimweg
schickte aber einfach über die schlag-
und wieder gegangen ist es so
verständliche beeindruckt vor dem
masters ausgelöst hat
das nicht realisiert die dem land roland
marx ist kein einzelfall
fachleute stellen bei simplen
auseinandersetzungen auf der straße eine
zunahme an brutalität fest immer öfter
landen die opfer von streitigkeiten im
spital
wenn wir bieten notfallaufnahme laguna
liegen
das ist sie gemacht wurden stellt man
fest dass es körperverletzung wo oft
kopf gerichtet sind zur hand das heißt
also habt allgemeine zunahme von gewalt
unter jungen männern hat auch qualität
von der gewalt zur knop ist also nicht
bereit ein auftrag gehört eine kreativ
mit der gewalt das ist ein großer
unterschied zu früheren wo doch
einigermaßen nur dass eben um eine
gewisse rahmen sich verhalten hat
[Musik]
in den vergangenen 20 jahren hat auch
das ausmaß an gewalttätigen
auseinandersetzungen unter jungen
männern zugenommen besonders in gruppen
die gewalt idealisieren viel alkohol
konsumieren und rund um die uhr
unterwegs sind
für die sanität ist der einsatz im fall
roland marx routine
[Musik]
im triemlispital verschlechtert sich
rollis gesundheitszustand er schwebt in
unmittelbarer lebensgefahr
er muss ins unispital verlegt und ins
künstliche koma versetzt werden
[Musik]
rolli hat nicht nur einen mehrfachen
schädelbruch sondern auch eine
lebensbedrohliche hirnblutung am abend
erreicht das unispital die eltern von
roland marx und ruft sie ans krankenbett
ausführliche lang dem bett wo sich
keinster weise kommen bewegen und nur
eins werden jetzt weiß oft nicht macht
dann der eigentliche vergisst immer
unser stil mit dem stelle notfall open
im osz in das rümelin 12 und forscht
eigentlich regnete es geht fast nicht
mehr
das ist da ist ganz tief saß
also der
wo einfach nur dass dieses großen wie
ist die große flasche oder einfache zeit
das ist einfach kaputt ist kaputt und so
fehlen so wählen eigentlich versteht
wenig von medizinischen alltag seite
also stammhirn ist zerstört um hat er an
immergrünen selber schlafen und selber
bewegt sich auch nimmer kein überhaupt
immer sich bewegen
das opfer konnte natürlich und so massiv
stehen schon an der werther vertragen
denn er würde überleben und ja man hat
es also künftig am tag wo sie häufig
noch damals
[Musik]
die zürcher kantonspolizei sucht nach
zeugen
obwohl sie die autonummer des
tatfahrzeugs kennt benötigt sie neun
tage bis sie am wohnort des täters
eintrifft insgesamt hat das aus meiner
sicht
juli länger tura das ist ja
schwerwiegende verletzung sie um
möglichst schnell natürlich am tag
danach
damit da nicht irgendwas passiert also
zum beispiel mit züge absprache passiert
für außenstehende die interessanten tag
aber wenn wir im detail betrachtet immer
wieder den tag vergangen ist mal wieder
person gehört wo noch mehr kleine sagen
damit man schlussendlich das puzzle
stucki zusammenkommt ich sah lange zeit
doch dann ist es soweit
diesmal gibt es kein entrinnen mehr
[Musik]
die fanta nehmen den täter vom zürcher
oberland zur einvernahme nach zürich mit
sie hat frage mag merkt dass inters
nicht schwer doch bewege
das ganze hat zwar schon zwei trainer
und tokio
das ist scheiße was passiert ist da
sitzt er verletzt ist und das solide
wähler aber zum schluss über das ganze
ist er nicht der mensch wo jetzt wo ich
sehen die möglichkeit gut also wirklich
checke der donots angestellt hat das für
folgen hat für sofa und dass er die zahl
nicht wo jetzt konsequent zu muss tragen
und dass er eine schulische oder
schwerwiegende verletzten der täter ist
ein 23-jähriger schweizer einen beruf
hat er kennengelernt
er arbeitet als kanal reiniger in der
freizeit trainiert er fußball junioren
auch er ist fcz im letzigrund besucht er
die spiele seines vereins regelmäßig
dort fällt er bereits eine woche vor der
tat durch hohe gewaltbereitschaft auf er
kassiert ein zweijähriges stadionverbot
nachdem er einem fcz offiziellen mit dem
tod droht wenn ich dich erwische bist du
tot
[Musik]
roland marx muss immer wieder operiert
werden
auf die lebenserhaltenden maschinen ist
er nicht mehr angewiesen
aber er lebt in seiner eigenen welt hier
in bellikon
der suva besuchen ihn seine eltern oft
in dieser zeit bekommen kleinste
fortschritte große bedeutung
ja ja noch im becken und augen
aufgemacht hat doch obwohl ich da können
dann ist das schon mal was sie sind mein
mann sich in countries überhaupt
unterschiedlich ein einziger vorschlag
rolli zehn monate später
meldet er hoffe dass beträge bis ist
wegen der bis vor ca
ob es besser wird
roland marx ist vollständig gelähmt nur
kleinste bewegungen sind möglich
sprechen können nicht auf fragen
reagierte mit handzeichen hirn und
nervenstränge sind schwerstverletzt
gewisse verbesserungen sind zu erwarten
ein vor zustand in dem sinne dass die
lähmungen verschwunden sind wird es
nicht geben muss auch noch das jetzt
dass der an tour stand sollen sie für
anwohner und das ist schon ganz motorik
ganze traurige situation 7 nun ganz
schweren können ohne aber an der börse
sind nur zehn oder noch aus und wenn man
da einfach
die situation so ordnen und immer wieder
kritik oft einen monat nach dem
ernüchternden befund der ärztin erhält
rolli besuch vom fcz und spricht erste
worte
für die super gilt roland maag ein jahr
nach dem faustschlag als weitgehend
austherapiert er kann zwar einzelne
worte sprechen muss aber künstlich
ernährt werden und sitzt im pflege
rollstuhl für christoph irdisch den
anwalt von roland marx ist der fall eine
große herausforderung sich nur geringere
das geschehnis was was passiert ist
das heißt ich habe mich vollständig marl
seinen auftakt verlor und durch seine
nackten uhse ist für mich klar wurde
aufgrund der aussage vom täter und
versichert wie aber auf andere züge
das büro liegt praktisch keinerlei als
bahnhof für den vorschlag medizinische
gutachter ist für mich kein wunder dass
der vorschlag extrem hart muss sie das
trolley einzigen baum hin müsse kritisch
und es ist auch aktiv das tiroler
kritisch und formiert sich das hat das
bag seit das hieße das dass theorien
immer 100 prozent fixiert und nawa und
die züge haben das bestätigt das hat für
mich ist das gesamtbild nicht
kunden haben mit einem kontext haben
immer einfach nur von heftigkeit also
von rollo sorgfaltspflicht verletzte
also man durch meter hinter der muss
mindestens in kauf genommen also
angerichtet hat
durch alle instanzen bis hinauf ins
bundesgericht streiten in der folge die
konfliktparteien ob der täter fahrlässig
oder vorsätzlich gehandelt hat
wenn man jetzt durfte sich vom druck
dann tut den täter wo ich mental
vorsätzlich handelt der schlag so fest
er merkt dass da sichert einmal umkehr
wird und dass ich meine völlig egal ob
da jetzt geplant
kabarett oder um boden irgendwie hart
aufschlag und eventuelle bildenden
schwere körperverletzung resultiert eine
wo fahrlässig handelt der story und
wortwahl verletzten aber erwartet dass
ich mir bestimmen es passiert und er
vertraut irgendwie dass ihr typischer
burka dass das wird nicht gravierend
passieren
erste instanz das zürcher bezirksgericht
der staatsanwalt sieht die möglichkeit
der täter habe eine schwere
körperverletzung in kauf genommen gar
nicht in betracht
die anklage lautet auf fahrlässige
schwere körperverletzung an roland maag
das gericht folgt der staatsanwaltschaft
und verurteilte den täter zu einer
freiheitsstrafe von drei jahren
die hälfte davon soll er absitzen also
18 monate gefängnis
es ist natürlich wieder schmerzt sie das
gericht hat sich kai tat sondern auch
relative tiefe strafkick noack tue ich
was mir aber hoffnung gemacht hat ist
dass die minderheitsrechte hat im
richtergremium das hat für mich zeigt
dass michelle sich nicht völlig falsch
schreiben sie und hat zusammen mit
angehörigen von roll im abgestellten vw
das ziel
nach jahrelanger therapie kann roland
marx wieder kurze strecken gehen
er kehrt an den ort zurück der nach dem
reha-zentrum bellikon zu seinem wohnort
wird das pflegezentrum needle bat in
seiner heimatgemeinde rüschlikon
hier trifft er auf ein junges
enthusiastisches pflegeteam mit dabei
yvonne stauffer mit ihr verbindet ihn
seither eine innige freundschaft
es braucht sehr schnell und richtig
gemacht
das pflegezentrum lidl bad ist für die
meisten bewohner die letzte station in
ihrem leben
roland marx ist mit großem abstand der
jüngste patient es nun auch für
transporter 21 x 28
mein gott er ist so jung soo jung und
darunter das pflegeheim eigentlich sagen
nur ältere lied und seine vorstellungen
alle schlacht sagte rische sowie für die
landtags- sie nicht richtig von der nasa
verschnitt klassischen künstler nach
wurde mir hat im flecken also sitze ich
ja das ist so und die zieht wo sie
darauf erbracht hat
so oder so und das war es ja nicht
nehmen ein
die wunstorfer und das pflegeteam
motivieren roli maag alles zu geben um
gesund zu werden
[Applaus]
mit den kollegen freunde wiedersehen
motto grillieren ein fußballmatch der
musik gab es muss auch für tier habe ich
hatte ich nur unterstützen aber der
wille und das team eigentlich aber
leider funktioniert das nicht
und dann haben irgendwie ein schalter
sache denn eigentlich ist motivation der
hirsch alaska und natürlich auch sehr
viel gemacht wir haben den mittleren
sehen aber wir sehen das kino und dass
er mir alles in der freizeit gemacht und
anja party gegangen sind geholt und
dabei waren da der rollstuhlfahrer
stunden ist natürlich eine
ja foto klein wir endlich mal tränen
es stimmt einfach
im sommer 2007 nehmen rollis
betreuerinnen in metz an ein benefiz
spiel seines lieblingsklubs der fcz
setzt ein signal im kampf gegen gewalt
und sammelt geld für seinen verletzten
fan gewalt unter jungen männern wird zu
dieser zeit immer mehr zum öffentlichen
thema
der anwalt von roland marx zieht das
urteil des bezirksgerichtes ans
obergericht weiter
dieses trifft einen entscheid der
überraschend und in der schweizer
rechtssprechung selten ist wo man
diskutiere nicht der erste fonds aus
oberkirch zurück
waren das was der beschuldigte gemacht
habe mich mit meiner sehr heftigen
faustschlag ins gesicht verletzt worden
dass sie da sich aufgenommen hat die
verletzung anstatt also so oder auch
angegriffen und darum muss nach lage
zurück so verbessert sich zu ärgern sich
dass sowohl die verlesung der optik als
auch die vorsätzlich umschrieben ist das
gleich bei die möglichkeit hat zu prüfen
das heißt für sie hat von anfang an
möglichkeit bestanden dass es ein
eventuell vorsatz quasi wie sophie rois
hat sich die frage aufdrängt aber die
hand sie nicht fertig dürfen wir sie
darauf nicht umschreiben
und dazu muss man mit dem konkreten fall
er wisse dass ein wandel ght der
auffassung bis heute keine
körperverletzung das hat ein früherer
standardmäßig als einfache
körperverletzung angeklagt und die
zwischenzeit ist darüber mit einem
bewusstseinswandel das als schwerwiegend
eingestuft wurde und darum ist es zurück
risiko und dann eben zu ihrer schwester
ergänzte auch mal geschafft
rekord des obergerichts zeit die auch
logisch wenig geschafft sie ja gut der
hand sie mit fahrlässigkeit oder vorsatz
oder ibm sehen haben wir ja das ist so
aber ich bin überzeugt dass es grob
fahrlässiges verhalten greifen toll
vorsatz staatsanwaltschaft das ist aber
auf die briefe wird verteidigung
addierten sich auf china fällig wenn sie
zwei schienen oder 1 auf sendung
schicken sie ihren eigenen standpunkt
abschreckt also sie kam zur tür rein
standpunkt und wann der übernahme wird
dann auch architekt sich das gericht
aber nicht und ich habe gedacht ich
würde ohne boden dann schoss sie da auch
noch die innenstadt dann führt das
gehört dazu dass man etwas muss er ganze
hoffnung für rollis familie
der fall muss zurück zum bezirksgericht
[Musik]
ronnie schlauri roland marx begleiter in
der tatnacht sammelt unterdessen geld
für seinen schwer verletzten freund ihn
hatte auch einen song gewidmet
das ist als ob sie dass ich das ganze
land haben war das gestartete gott genug
das haben wir vor arbeite mit einer
musikpause und unter den insgesamt für
nicht lernen dahinter entstehen dass man
die betonung auf vermisst
er habe dennoch nicht
mit dem an der party gesammelten geld
wollen die freunde rolli einen traum
erfüllen war mir dass ich spieler war
und das auch noch sparen geld und so
spannend wie der kampf ausbilden
[Musik]
2011 verhandelt das zürcher
bezirksgericht den fall roland marx ein
zweites mal
es unterstützt die ansicht des
obergerichtes nicht der täter könnte die
verletzung des opfers in kauf genommen
haben
das urteil lautet erneut auf fahrlässige
schwere körperverletzung
der anwalt des täters stellt sich
ausnahmsweise der fernsehkamera als
sieger
franken sichergestellt ich hatte drei
einziges mal zugeschlagen hat müssen
damit rechnen dass es derart gravierend
die frage hat und dass ich sie
geschlagen hat die verletzungen der
umschlag auf dem boden wo sie geduldig
wirklich strapaziert wurden
diesbezüglich aber aus uwe hammer
verdankt die familie von roland marx
will die niederlage nicht hinnehmen und
zieht den fall erneut ans obergericht zu
der instanz die schon einmal die
hoffnung geweckt hat sie könnte den
täter für eventuelle vorsatz verurteilen
dafür habe in kauf genommen sein opfer
zu verletzen
heute lebt roland maag in operierten er
bezieht eine iv-rente das wohnhaus bären
los bietet menschlich einer körperlichen
behinderung die möglichkeit ihr leben
selbstbestimmt zu bewältigen
hier geht rolli einer regelmäßigen
beschäftigung nach die ihn erfüllt dem
motto sei nicht glücklich mit sie habe
damit begonnen habe und ich sage bildes
das dass ich frau die stimmen zum reden
am telefon
und dass endlich haben wir also gern zu
mir auskunft wo ich musste ja mal
blieben
rolli ist inzwischen 35 schritt für
schritt nähert er sich seinem ziel
wieder selbstständig zu werden
in bern los bewohnt rolli ein kleines
studio sein reich pflege und hilfe im
haushalt kann er bei bedarf in anspruch
nehmen
seit nunmehr sechs jahren kämpfen
familie und opferanwalt für ihre
überzeugung der täter habe in kauf
genommen rolle zu verletzen
und tatsächlich die zweite instanz das
zürcher obergericht gibt ihnen im märz
2012 recht und urteilt der schläger habe
eventuell vorsätzlich gehandelt
das verdikt lautet auf vier jahre
gefängnis und jetzt du das ziel erreicht
dass die täter die schöne natur und die
relativ relativ kurze frist eu strafe
absitzen
wenn man bedenkt dass der wohl im grund
nur lebenslänglich hat die andere strafe
maxi maxi sie wie sie will ist
bescheiden
das ist mir wieder besser geht aber will
ihn wegen abschluss das heißt sie nur
kredite zurücklegen auch wieder wenn ich
das immer gemacht haben und so haben wir
am meisten
woher nehmen sie die zuversicht
ja ich kann für jede darf ich sagen
würde also die bz braucht
[Musik]
doch der anwalt des täters will den fall
so nicht abschließen
er legte rekurs ein im herbst 2012
sechseinhalb jahre nach der tat fällt
das bundesgericht ein wegweisendes
urteil
es bestätigt das urteil des
obergerichtes einstimmig und verurteilt
den täter wegen eventuell vorsatz die
strafe lautet vier jahre gefängnis
es liegt im zeichen oder zieht dass man
gar keine bekommt weniger tolerant tisch
und das spiegelt sich jetzt in acht
sprachen
aus meiner sicht ist das auch richtig
will schlag auf den kopf die sehen die
bis gravierend und da kann einiges
passieren
das bedeutet also dass personen wo
driesch lernt also mit voller gewalt und
hass jeder mitmachen
dass sie sehr schwer bestraft werden
dass das erhöht nur toleriert wird und
zu einer freiheitsstrafe wird unter
schwerer körperverletzung funktionierte
[Musik]
für den täter bedeutet das
letztinstanzliche urteil statt 18 monate
vier jahre vollzug seine strafe sitzt er
seit märz dieses jahres in der
strafanstalt pöschwies ab
[Musik]
der schlag mitten ins gesicht hat roland
marx beinahe das leben gekostet
[Musik]
ein klein wenig ist es heute wieder wie
früher
und doch ist alles anders doch der
meister
[Musik]
die stunde